if you could do something that would
make you less depressed to be successful
wouldn't you want to take that drug
every day you've got to tell me what it
is so it is Scott Galloway he's a public
speaker and author and marketing
professor at NYU it's a business World
rock star and I'm not done yet the
number of kids who see their friends
every day has been cut in half in the
last 10 years the knock-on effect here
is that we're producing too many of what
is the most dangerous person in the
world and that is a young broken alone
man
they get this illusion that they have
worth and when they say angry
misogynistic content on social media
they become just really shitty citizens
Andrew takes us self-described
misogynist if a woman is going out with
a man she belongs to that man is Andrew
Tate's message a symptom of what you've
described 100 they're out of [ __ ]
control how would we go about solving
this problem so
so life gets very hard very fast 25 to
45. and generally speaking these are the
least happy years and then something
wonderful happens you find joy in the
mundane as you get older and you get
happier so I think it's helpful just to
know that when you say something stupid
at a party when you say something unkind
and you're just beating yourself up you
need to forgive yourself and you need to
realize what feels important in the
moment isn't that important happiness
Waits For You
what are you still working on I'm trying
to slow time down time is falling off a
cliff for me but how does one
practically slow time down so that 30
years doesn't fly past I find you can
slow time down by
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the diver CEO if I can have any favors
from you if you've ever watched this
show and enjoyed it it's just to please
hit the Subscribe button without further
Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this is the
Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
let's go
give me your context what is the
necessary context that I'd have to
understand about you and your earliest
years to make sense of the person that
you went on to be in your life
wow that's a thoughtful question
um raised by a single immigrant mother
who lived and died a secretary
a light of my life you know I think the
most important thing in anyone's life is
to have someone who's rationally
passionate about your well-being and I
add that
and the second thing is I was born
in
California in the 60s a white
heterosexual male which was like hitting
hitting a lottery
I got access to amazing free education I
went to UCLA and Berkeley for a graduate
and undergraduate degrees total tuition
seven thousand dollars
and Not only was it accessible
financially it was accessible period at
the admissions rate at UCLA when I
applied was 76 percent it's now six
percent
and I mentioned my uh sexuality because
my freshman roommate in college was born
a white homosexual male and was dead of
AIDS at the age of 33.
so you know a lot of My Success whether
it was free education coming of age
during the internet age which was
incredible wind in your economic sales
you know a lot of My Success is not my
fault so the two things that
I try and remember to Define my start
and it was an amazing start where one
uh you know someone who was rationally
passionate about my well-being and being
born in America and just being
exceptionally fortunate
you mentioned your mother there what
about your father my dad uh you know not
a bad man she left us for lack of a
better term when I was eight
you know it was in the 70s he started
his third marriage while he was still
married to my mom uh neither my parents
are very sophisticated uh
they were both pulled out of school at
the age of 13.
my dad was a handsome Scott living in La
which means he not only thought with his
dick he could listen to it and so he you
know just really enjoyed himself for
lack of a better term which didn't foot
well to
uh you know a family life so he wasn't
very involved in my life
growing up but I I feel compelled to say
now that he's 92.
every person's obligation from a species
level is to be a better father or mother
than their father or mother was to them
and he was definitely that he was he
grew up in terrible circumstances
and he always tried to do the right
thing but it was you know it was me and
my mom was it happy childhood any of you
it was entirely you you were talking
about a little bit about your childhood
it was entirely unremarkable I feel like
on a scale of 100 100 being the best
childhood in the world one being the
worst in America at least I was like a
50. it wasn't bad you know we didn't
have any we didn't have we were upper
lower middle class but it wasn't a sob
story in America in the 70s you could
make you you could survive on a
secretary's salary we took vacations I
didn't go to good schools but they were
bad schools I had friends but not a lot
of friends I I you know my high school
reunion was recently no one would
remember me my childhood was remarkably
unremarkable it wasn't bad it's not a
sob story but it wasn't what I would
call
great with a lot of support and a lot of
accoutrements but again the context of
it is being at the median in California
in the 70s was like hitting the lottery
it was the highest median in the world
what was your relationship like with
money because I I remember reading that
that was um quite your relationship with
my your family's relationship with money
was quite formative money very early had
a big impact on me because you know
people say oh at the time having a
divorced mom felt like a little bit of a
not a Scarlet Letter but you were the
kid who lived with his mother
but the thing that was harder was we
didn't have any money I mean we weren't
poor but you know you apply to college
and if you didn't get into UCLA which I
didn't get in there were no options we
didn't have the confidence or the
contacts or the money to apply for me to
apply to college outside of school it
was stressful
and but it was also in some ways very
motivating my mom got sick when I was a
young adult and I me being the only
child and some of those you know
instincts that a son feels for his
mother take over and when my mom got
sick I decided all right I I remember
coming home one weekend she was very ill
and I remember thinking a kind of like
I'm not doing my job as a man because I
don't have the money to take care of her
and that was really emasculating and
that's when I kind of got my [ __ ]
together I remember the moment it was
when I was in graduate school I was 26.
and look I I decided very early and
people I think people who have achieved
some level of wealth aren't entirely
forthcoming or honest I think about
money a lot I was very focused on it I
decided very early that I was going to
have Economic Security I did nothing but
pretty much work for 20 years I don't
remember much else but work
it cost me my hair it cost me my first
marriage and was worth it
is there a risk in that that when we
become so orientated by money yep we
I've said this I've had this
conversation with a few guests about are
we really driven or are we being dragged
and
and how do we make sure we're not being
dragged
so we can be intentional about living
lives in line with our values yeah I'm
not I'm not proposing this is what the
world should be I'm proposing what it is
in a capitalist society and that is I
think America I just moved here so I
don't know if Society is different here
I have noticed here that people ask you
where you're from in America they ask
you what you do but America becomes more
like itself every day and that it is a
it is a kind generous place if you have
money it's a rapacious violent place if
you don't have money
and I figured that out very very soon
the way I saw it was that poor people
having an entirely different experience
with U.S health care System than rich
people
um I just saw it as if I want to have a
life of opportunity of prosperity
selection set of mates even love to be
to be wealthy in America is to be loved
people find you interesting they want to
know you you have a broader selection
set of mates it is the idolatry of the
dollar and the impact that wealth has on
your life in America is unfortunate and
100 true and it gets more true every day
and one of the things I coach young
people around is you just have to figure
out a way to become economically viable
I'm not saying you need to do what I did
and work all the time and be very kind
of have a monocular focus on money which
I did I think there's a lot of people
who decide they're not going to live to
work they're going to work to live
and they move to a lower cost region
they live within their means and they
have really good lives I think that's a
nice way to live your life the majority
of young people I'm around by virtue of
the fact I teach at a business school
expect to not only mean the top 10
percent they expect me in the top one
percent economically and so what I
encourage young people to do is have a
sober conversation what do you where do
you expect to be economically
and the majority of young people you
talk to
expect to be in the top one percent
and I don't know anyone who's gotten
there who didn't inherit money who
didn't sacrifice a lot you know what I
tell young people is you can't have it
all you just can't have it all at once
and I think in this competitive
environment to be great in anything
uh you not only need talent you not only
need luck you just need a tremendous
amount of grit and a tremendous
commitment there are some people who are
so talented that they can have balance
in a life at a young age and get
Economic Security
I think you should assume you're not one
of those people and assume that like
most of us who have achieved some level
of Economic Security it's required a
significant trade-off
it came at a cost it came at a cost of
relationships
it came at a cost of stress I mean it
takes a toll but the reason I have
balance in my life right now I have a
lot of balance in my life right now is
because I didn't have very much when I
was your age when I was young I mean
you're an entrepreneur
it's hard to phone it in as an
entrepreneur it just requires a level of
people think we're just so we're
extraordinarily talented that we're just
blessed with some special skill I would
argue that you're you have more of a
risk appetite you're willing to endure
public failure because there's no
blaming anyone else in your business you
know crashes it's very public failure
and also more than anything you have a
natural instinct to be thinking about
the business all the time and working at
it most of the time
that's you know there's there's a
relationship between intelligence and
success but it tops out at about 110 120
IQ it's better to be smart you're more
likely to be successful if you're smart
but the difference between being smart
and being genius has no correlation
between success that's where grit and
perseverance and resilience take over
I want to continue that thread but on
one of the things you said at the start
of this conversation was about your
mother's she got sick I read that she
you remember the day when you realized
that she was depressed yep how did that
shape your views on happiness and
fulfillment and depression and how we
how we ultimately end up in a situation
where we're suffering with depression
did was that at all
did that influence your view on
happiness watching your mother be become
depressed yeah my mom was sincerely
depressed severely depressed but I
remember
um and that's one of the wonderful
things about our liberal arts uh
education I took psychology and they
started talking about clinical
depression and what it meant and I
realized that's what my mom was
suffering from and depression is sort of
the cancer of Our Generation and that is
it used to be closeted now people are
openly talking about it and it's really
helpful because I wish I'd known what my
mom was going through earlier
because you immediately you know we're a
narcissistic species you really think
something you've done it's not about you
usually it's about them and also life
isn't about what happens to you it's
about how you respond to what happens to
you and I think it's very helpful when
you recognize
depression and understand it and
recognizing other people because what
you then realize is that when you're
feeling really down a lot of times it's
not your fault you may have substantial
reason to be depressed but you may not a
lot of it is about your Chemistry that
day and also to recognize that this too
shall pass that nothing is saying that's
been really important to me and it's one
of the few things that so it's kind of
held its water for me is nothing is ever
as good or as bad as it seems when you
feel like you're killing it when you
feel like you're on top of the world
that's absolutely the time to bring in
your horns and be humble and grateful
and realize a lot of your success isn't
your fault you just got lucky
and at the same time when you're upset
when you're angry yourself when you're
depressed when you feel like
everything's just black it's not that's
that's temporary and you it's comforting
to know that that will pass
understanding what my mom was going
through was external that it wasn't
because things are so bad for us or so
bad for her that this was a chemical
thing this was like catching a cold that
was really liberating and helpful not
only to manage the situation in our
household
but to recognize when I was down and
also to recognize that I was probably
going to be more prone or vulnerable to
that type of depression
um but just being aware of these things
you know you're a young man when I was a
kid we didn't talk about depression we
used to call it a nervous breakdown and
it was a sign of weakness and it only
happened to women
right they were the weaker gender and
they had something called a nervous
breakdown that was what mental health
that's what Depression was called back
then and then slowly but surely people
started to acknowledge that it was a
thing that it was no different than any
other type of illness that was treatable
and that it wasn't a sign of Shame so it
was really helpful for me it was it was
uh
um you know liberating to kind of
understand it and realize that it wasn't
totally a function of our situation or
an indication of how good or bad things
were at the time
one of the things you talk about in your
new book adrift
um is this decay of community in our
lives yeah and Community seems like such
a human thing yeah
so I I when I read that I thought maybe
that's in part part of the
part of the cause or factor of why we're
seeing a lot of um unhappiness
depression and these things what should
we take on that 100
um do you have dogs I need them yeah I
do have a dog upstairs so look dogs just
want to be around other beings and
mammals are a social we're very social
we you know from a young age we cycle
we're we just want to my dogs lie on top
of each other I mean we're meant to be
around each other and
whether it's in the U.S and Roman and
Boy and Girl Scouts is off by like 40
percent Church attendance is way down
the percentage of people who speak to
their neighbors is off like 40 percent
you just think about covid we don't go
to mall we don't go to movie theaters
right we're becoming more and more
segregated by income class the number of
kids who see their friends every day has
been cut in half in the last 10 years
so we're just not touching smelling and
feeling each other nearly as much and I
think that's directly correlated to
happiness my youngest really struggled
with covet and we always said
well it's because he's not in school
because the schools were closed for a
while and I thought more than school
what my kid needs is other kids
and that is
you know that you need guard rails you
need people around you I think of those
Japanese
soldiers who retreated into the hills of
the Philippines with orders to not give
up the islands you know when the
Japanese were true from the Philippine
islands in the South Pacific they left
behind some of these soldiers
some of them were there for 20 or 30
years
and they refused to give up their
commission until they would have to find
the the commanding officer take them to
the island and tell them come down the
war's been over for 25 years these
individuals accomplish nothing they
didn't grow spiritually physically
physically they didn't learn anything
they had nothing to share with anyone
after their 25 years
so being alone is one of the worst
things on an extended basis that can
happen to a human and every day one of
the worst things that can happen to a
human is happening more and more to all
of us in Western society and it's
especially prevalent among kids the lack
of socialization and then this kind of
hyper socialization that takes place on
their phone which is really brutal and
has huge externalities is I think one of
the biggest causes for the massive
uptick in depression among young people
so again I like to coach younger people
I'm like put yourself in a position
where you have to be around other people
every day building something in the
agency of something else whether it's a
job whether it's a non-profit whether
it's Church whether it's a sports League
be in the agency of others building
something bigger than all of you and
it's a great way to make friends mentors
it's a great way to learn how to read
the room I joined a fraternity when I
went to UCLA when I was 17 and people
make a cartoon of fraternity like we're
all these terrible people it was the
best thing I could have done I had no
male role models until the age of 17 my
dad wasn't around I didn't have many
friends so being in a place that shrunk
a 30 000 person campus down to a smaller
thing I wouldn't have graduated
and it was hard for me these my
quote-unquote for Chamber brothers gave
me a hard time but it was really good
for me you know you you you you get in
better shape I remember I remember my
roommates telling me to stop smoking so
much pot and go to class more I mean you
have people watching you 24x7
I needed that socialization so I think
one of the worst things that can happen
to a young adult is for them to be
isolated and we're increasingly isolated
are you optimistic about that that
changing because the direction of travel
is in Wonder is in One Direction and
then when you hear things about
metaverses yeah I'm not I think we have
this nihilistic I think technology is
nihilistic I think the most successful
person in the world at least monetarily
wants to figure out a way to inhabit
another planet rather than Focus as
genius and as resources on making this
planet more habitable
and I find that nihilistic and uh people
I just find it strange that the most
talented wealthiest people in the world
want to get us off the planet
so and then you think about social media
just the trends among young people
there's an uptick in travel but that's
pent-up Demand by uh class people who
have the money to travel
our socialization appears to have taken
a dramatic step change structural step
change down and I even see to my kids
they are thinking about getting home to
their phones and they're social on their
phones but it's not a replacement for
for person-to-person contact
um you know there's some good things to
it uh Team drunk driving accidents are
now in team pregnancy is way down
but the number of kids socializing is
way off I find it I think it's a I think
it's a terrible thing and I don't see
there'll be some uptick because covet's
over but it feels like there's been a
structural step change down because
people now want the dopa they get
trading on Robin Hood watching porn
watching Netflix uh getting some sort of
socialization or need for affirmation by
the number of likes to get on Twitter
rather than leaving their house to get
that same type of dopa hit the number of
people playing in organized Sports is
way down
so I'm not I think it's I think it's a
real problem and I don't see it
unless there's ex unless there's
recognition of it and external
investment whether it's youth clubs
whether it's after school programs
whether it's some sort of
conscription or national service which
I'm a big fan of I don't see structured
means for people young people to serve
in the agency of something bigger than
themselves
do you think there's a decline decline
in grit amongst young people that this
gen Z generation in the in the Western
World when you think about your kids in
the and the grit they'll have you talked
about how important grit is to to
achieving economic viability
um
I was talking to Simon cynic about this
a couple of weeks ago on this podcast
about whether gen Z are less resilient
and hard-working than Generations that
have come before them because of the
influences I remember I opened up Tick
Tock the other day and it's like it's
showing I don't know whether this was
just the tick tock I saw I remember one
going viral on Twitter a couple of weeks
ago from San Francisco showing the day
and the life of um a gen Z working in in
Tech and it's like wake up go get the
frappucca latte whatever take the dog
for a while take the dog for a pottery
class yeah
I love that five minutes on the laptop
Pottery glasses yeah
yeah
yoga
I worry about this a lot with my kids
because generally speaking what happens
is the children
of
I would say if I had what my kids have I
wouldn't have what I have
because I was not motivated if I'd grown
up in the household I'm growing my kids
are growing up now the only two things I
know I would have had in my life as a
young man are a Range Rover in a cocaine
habit I just wasn't an absence of money
really motivated me and my kids don't
have that my kids have access to
everything they need
and so trying to figure out a way to
instill grit in your kids whether it's
chores
or some level of discipline it's my I
think it's my biggest challenges or our
biggest challenges parents uh
um but in terms of the I work with and
granted it's selection by us I work the
kids I work with I can't get over how
extraordinarily talented they are
um so the meme of quiet quitting
and again it may be proximity bias
because of the kids I draw or I I know
in my firm but I find that every year
and I teach between three and 500 kids a
year at NYU every year I find that the
kids the young adults are more talented
and harder working and more socially
conscious sure they're a little
expectant some of it I roll my eyes you
know occasionally I'll say someone say
you know I I need to leave and go to to
pilates class and I kind of laugh like I
can't even imagine saying that to my
boss when I started out but in general I
find they're just remarkable
um and again it might be because the
kids I've been able to attract but I
don't buy this notion that they're
somehow entitled I don't I haven't seen
that
when you when you're teaching these
young people about and preparing them
mentally and with skills for the the
world that's to come what is a key
indicator that that young person will
become a successful adult professional
entrepreneur business owner yeah
I can't speak to entrepreneur we're very
data German so I ran I started around a
company called L2 which was a business
intelligence firm we grew it to about
120 people and we sold it
and we were very data driven and we used
to
you know evaluate everybody every year
and then we would try and look for
um
correlations
and while it's dangerous to do and no
one wrote it down the correlations we
found that were the best predictors of
success at our firm were a few things
one they went to a grade school which
you don't like to say but most of our
kids who are really really strong had
gone to what you would consider Elite
universities uh two they were athletes
we found that a background in sports
especially individual sports whether
it's gymnastics or diving uh that these
people just brought a certain level of
discipline and grit that some of the
others didn't have and the third is
female uh they because we had such a
young firm uh disproportionate amount of
our really successful people
were women and there's a lot of studies
showing now that women just mature at an
earlier age the net of it for us was and
you were scared to write it down and
I've sold the firm so I can say it now
if a woman from the Yale gymnastics team
showed up it was an automatic hire
and I don't think that's anything
unusual
that groundbreaking the
you know I graduate from UCLA with a
2.27 GPA I don't know if you have grades
the value but basically I barely
graduated
and I got a job at Morgan Stanley right
out of UCLA which was considered a
pretty prestigious firm and it's because
the guy who ran the department
had rode crew and I was an ordersman at
UCLA and he said anyone who Rose crew
gets an automatic hire because you're
willing to kill yourself you can push
yourself harder than anyone
yeah so a lot of these firms recognize
that sports are a forward-looking
indicator
but some of the other indicators you
can't control you know getting into an
elite University now is a function of
being
the the son or daughter of someone rich
or being freakishly remarkable
kind of two cohorts and then obviously
you can't control your sex but I have
several women in their early 20s working
for me who could be the junior Senator
it could be the next ambassador to
France and you know a lot of the young
men have a lot of potential but you can
just see they just don't mature as fast
what else are you teaching these kids
I call them kids they're my age but
yeah I well I mean it's mostly
principles of brand strategy and digital
marketing but I have of course uh I have
a session the most popular session is on
I call it the algebra of happiness and I
just go through sort of basic best
practices
for success and we've talked about some
of them realizing balance I think is a
myth I think the most important decision
you'll make in your 20s and 30s you know
I serve at the class
what's the most important decision to
make and they usually say the industry
you'll go into where you decide to live
the most important decision you'll make
is who you decide to partner with
specifically have kids because you're in
that person's life for 20 years and I
have a lot of friends who are successful
in most exterior metrics but don't have
a real partner in their spouse
and they have what I would call a life
full of
stress and disappointment on a regular
basis whereas I have friends who on an
external basis may not look as
successful but they have a real partner
and everything just burns brighter for
them so the most important decision
you'll make
is is who you're fortunate or not
fortunate enough to partner with
and so what I suggest is that they be as
aggressive as possible about creating as
many opportunities for Serendipity and
contact with people
that your your ability to punch above
your weight class and find someone a
great character that you're attracted to
that you fit with is a function of
liquidity and that is always accept
invitations to dinner parties I think
young men should be more aggressive I
think young men have been told in this
environment that they should be very
careful about who they approach and
express interest in and I think there is
a huge difference between expressing
interest in a thoughtful way and
harassing someone and if you don't know
the difference you've got much bigger
problems but I encourage young men to as
general cognitive or behavioral therapy
to force themselves when they're in a
line of coffee to talk to some the guy
or gal in front of them and behind them
because if you're interested in someone
there's nothing wrong with asking them
out to Coffee there's nothing wrong with
expressing interest
and I see a lot of young men are not
creating that types of opportunities to
meet people and eventually find good
friends find good mentors and most
importantly find a good mate
and so unfortunately marriage and
relationships are becoming another
luxury item marriage and pairing off
with a mate is plummeting among people
it's it's correlated to your wealth
because middle income and poor people
especially men are no longer are because
of online dating are no longer seen as
viable mates and they also don't have as
many opportunities to meet people in
person where there's things like smell
and Vibe and humor that are some of the
magic mystery of why we're attracted to
each other
but
um what I tell them is create as many
opportunities as possible to establish
relationships
so it's give up balance but if and when
you can invest all of your remaining
energy and having as many uh you know
random contacts with people as possible
and also be aggressive talk to people
introduce yourself if you're interested
in someone if you want to establish a
friendship if you're interested in
someone romantically Express that
interest if they're not interested in
you both of you are going to be fine you
can handle the rejection or the small
rejection they can handle someone
expressing interest and I think in our
age we've uh in a weird way
implicitly told young people especially
men they're not supposed to express that
interest
what do you make of dating apps
well I think my advice to young people
would be to do it all
you know it's how people meet it used to
be how people made it if you will
is that it used to be a third work a
third friends and a third school now
it's well above 50 online
so the majority of relationships are
beginning online for people your age
and it's very efficient but what happens
when technology comes into any sector is
it consolidates it it becomes a winner
take most
market so whether it's
e-commerce social media search engines
once technology comes into it you have
one company that owns 50 of all online
retail
two-thirds of all social and 93 of
search
so technology has come into mating with
dating apps
and it's created a winner take all or
winner take most dynamic which is
somewhat unhealthy and it it plays out
like something like this
women are interested in men based on
three criteria the first is their
ability to Signal resources the second
is intelligence and the third is
kindness it doesn't matter how rich or
how smart you are if you're an [ __ ]
or you're not kind people eventually
don't want you as a mate
and unfortunately online it's very
difficult to Signal two and three so you
can signal one
and when everyone has access to everyone
women who have a much finer filter for
mating because the downside of sex is so
much greater for them if they get
pregnant so they have much finer filter
they end up all being drawn or
expressing interest to a much smaller
group of individuals so what the dynamic
is you have 50 men on Tinder 50 women on
Tinder 46 of the women will Express all
of their interest to just for men which
leaves 46 men vying for the attention of
just four women
so if you apply the genie coefficient to
online dating
it's got the same Genie coefficient as
income inequality in Venezuela so mating
inequality is greater than income
inequality in Venezuela and what it
leads to is what I call Porsche polygamy
and that is the men who are able who are
the top 10 percent in terms of
attractiveness online get 90 of the
interest
so that does not lead to good behavior
or establishing long-term relationships
kind of 50 to 90 percentile do okay but
the bottom half of attractiveness of men
based on online attractiveness are
totally shut out of the market and as a
result in America one in three males
under the age of 30 has not had sex in
the last 12 months
and I find people hear the term sex and
their mind goes different places I think
of it as the key step to an elemental
Foundation of any society and that is
relationship
so in the U.S what's happened with
online dating
is it's amazing for the top 10 percent
of attractiveness of men it's okay for
the top half it is a disaster for the
bottom half and when I say
attractiveness I mean by very crude
metrics so if your Tinder profile I went
to MIT I just started a KKR and my Rolex
accidentally is visible in my profile
picture and I'm geo-located living in
Manhattan or living in Beverly Hills
you're going to get a massive amount of
attention
the bottom half we're not able to
express anything other than wealth which
they may not have are totally shut out
of the market
and the knock-on effect here is that
we're producing too many of what is the
most dangerous person in the world and
that is a young broken alone man
so the guy attacked Salman rashti uh
recently in the U.S that wasn't about
the fatwa that was about a young man
living in his mother's basement when you
hear about Mass Shooters in the U.S you
know who they are before you know who
they are
so we are producing uh an enormous
cohort of economically and emotionally
non-viable men
and I think it's bad for society I think
it creates an existential risk for us I
think women as a result don't have as
many uh find there just aren't as many
economically or most or emotionally
valuable men as they would like women
are graduating at Double the rates of
college as men now for every one male
graduate the next five years of college
there's going to be two women
and you think well okay it's time women
it's time women leveled up they're
finally getting their due
okay but the this has just realized it
has huge societal impacts because women
made socioeconomically horizontally and
up men horizontally and down in some
women with college degree is typically
aren't interested in men without college
degrees
so we're seeing less household formation
lower birth rates and these things
usually stunt an economy
so I think it's a big issue uh and again
I think it comes down to providing more
young more opportunity for young people
in general I think if you had sort of
gender-specific affirmative action
towards men it would just become so
politicized and heated that it wouldn't
be worth it I think you need a massive
leveling up of all young people that I
think will disproportionately help young
men how do we get those 50 of young men
laid
I think you need to make them first and
foremost more economically viable
um I think more job opportunities
I think it builds confidence I think you
need to get them out of the house I
think it's vocational programs I think
it's opportunities to go to college or
get some sort of certification
I think it sings As basic as social
service or more opportunities for them
to get together Community yeah and I
think it's a certain amount of Education
that uh Embrace some of the things that
are wonderful to be about being a man
being aggressive is fine be physically
fit and strong I think we're blessed
with and this is true of men and women
I'm a big fan I believe they're a
forward-looking indicator of your
success is the amount of time you spend
sweating versus watching other people
sweat any person under the age of 30 man
or woman should be able to walk into any
room and think if [ __ ] got real I could
kill and eat everybody or outrun them
one or the other
and it's not about being ripped it's not
about being skinny it's about being a
stronger version of yourself you'll be
happier less prone to Depression more
attractive to other mates you'll be
kinder
because you'll feel more confident so I
think real embracing physical fitness
young people have one thing that's
terrible about young people as they've
gotten unhealthier consistently the last
50 years
I think social service and I think
figuring out institutions and means
whether it's school or social service so
they can meet each other develop
friendships fall in love have more
opportunities
to have not only make relationships but
have guardrails young men need guard
rails they need a girlfriend a job to
tell them no you need to pit on a shirt
and get into work no you can't get high
and drunk every night no if you want to
continue to have sex with me you need to
get your [ __ ] together I think that's
really important for a young man
especially young men and young women
need it as well but just not as much so
I think what you have is a generation of
young men that have no motivation no
guard rails they get their dope ahead of
Addiction on Robin Hood they don't have
the Mojo to get out there and meet women
as much because they're watching so much
porn they get they get this illusion
that they have some sort of Worth or
affirmation when they say angry things
on social media that they get rewarded
for they become they start blaming other
people specifically they start blaming
women and they become much more prone to
misogynistic content they start
believing in conspiracy theory they're
less likely to believe in climate change
and some they become just really shitty
citizens
and we're producing just a massive
amount of these individuals and the
scary part is
we'll just ignore the weirdo and put
them in the corner the problem is the
government doesn't ignore them
because we're very misogynistic when it
comes to our elected leaders in the U.S
we've been producing more female college
graduates and male college graduates for
the last 40 years
but still only 28 percent of our elected
representatives are female
people societies men and women conflate
leadership quality with height and depth
of voice so we will always at least in
the U.S for a long time elect more men
and who do these men appeal to how do
they get elected they appeal to this
cohort of conspiracy-driven misogynistic
anti-government man young men these
young men will always have
over-representation in government which
leads to elected leaders saying that
they believe the elections are rigged
that Stoke nationalist fears that blame
immigrants I mean really really hateful
stuff and so not only are these
individuals uh dangerous and
unproductive but what's even more
unproductive is they will have a
disproportionate voice in our politics
because the easiest way to get elected
is to tap into the tribal instincts or
motives of this of this cohort
you said misogynistic content there and
um one of the things that came to mind
when you said that was Andy Tate yeah
are you familiar with yeah this person
yeah is Andrew Tate's message a symptom
of
um what you've described
100 uh
you know we live look it's easy to
credit your grit and your character for
your successes and blame the markets for
your failures and so when you have a
young man who is failing he's looking
for culprits and then you have someone
come along and say it's not your fault
and and they start saying that the
reason you can't find a date it's
women's fault it's their fault it's not
yours it's not that you haven't
developed the skills
or demonstrated the discipline to
develop the attributes that others find
attractive it's their fault
and I think it's very
um dangerous and most of it's a grift
the individual you represented claims
it's not your fault in the bed by my
49.95 you know learn how to be
successful program it really is a grift
um and people you know Trump is sort of
a version of that right I mean if you
think about what's happening in America
the Democratic party is basically
becoming the party of educated women and
the Republican party is becoming the
party of uneducated men
so yeah I think uh I think that those
types of individuals are perfect
examples of trapping of a kind of
falling into this really ugly
you know blame others kind of uh
Gestalt in our society I think it's very
unfortunate I think we also on the I
have no idea what your politics are see
if I consider myself a progressive I
think progressives have to take back
masculinity and that is we have to
Define what masculinity means and show a
vision why are all the dudes these
conservatives so
I mean I'll give an example I'm a
profane and vulgar person and on the
left they immediately can play conflate
I've cursed several times on this show I
talk about sex very openly and very
crudely
that doesn't mean I'm not
that doesn't mean I'm not a feminist
doesn't mean I don't have Progressive
values so I think the left needs to take
back profanity and vulgarity and I think
we need to take back masculinity
I I see masculinity as a man-made
societal construct but to we need to
identify it and then ask young men to
foot to those skills and I see it as
very basic in a very basic way acquiring
the skills and strengths so you can
advocate for and protect others
whether it's physical strength metal
strength Financial strength kindness
intelligence
and I think saying okay it's great to be
a man express your masculinity and by
the way masculinity isn't just the
domain of people who are born men women
can demonstrate masculine features just
as men can demonstrate feminine features
but I think the left or progressives
need to take back this notion of
masculinity and we've sort of we've sort
of emasculated on the left men because
to be pro-man to even acknowledge
masculinity is somehow to be anti-female
on the left and that's not true at all
you know who wants more men women
or that's what I find
so I think that key to restoring balance
if you will and not having our party
split across gender lines
and pull this generation of failing
young men out of this hole is to
redefine masculinity as something more
evolved more thoughtful that involves
intelligence that involves kindness that
involves strength but also on the left
to say it's okay to be a man we can
acknowledge our differences it's okay to
be aggressive
you know when when Russians pour over
the Border in Ukraine you want some of
that big dick energy you know that's it
there's some features of of distinct to
uh uh uh a man that is really important
in our society and should be celebrated
and all of it has been in my opinion not
all of it a lot of it has been on the
left conflated with toxicity and there's
some of those attributes that can lead
to terrible Behavior
but most of it is a good thing in our
society most of it is needed quick one
some of you may know we've got a brown
response from this podcast American
Express and you've got a brand new
exclusive offer for a limited time only
which I can't wait to tell you about
from the 18th of October to the 16th of
November American Express is offering
new card members a 60 000 Point
membership reward as a welcome bonus
when you join when you spend a minimum
of 8 000 pounds across the first three
months this is simply a thank you for
joining American Express and for those
that don't know you can use your
American Express business platinum card
points in exchange for various rewards
such as booking travel holidays gift
cards and so much more so essentially
you're rewarded with huge prizes for
just using their card to spend on your
usual purchases and I've had a look
through at what sixty thousand points
can get you so if you'd like to find out
how you can get your hands on your new
American Express business card then
search American Express business
platinum card to find out more as you
might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when I put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafted jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made there was a
big smile on the front of your book yeah
part of the reason why you put that
what looks like a smiley face on it is
because because of this Arc of happiness
that you describe yeah that was quite
surprising to me what do you mean by an
arc of Happiness well across across
almost every culture the correlation
between age and happiness is a smile so
zero to kind of 25 is beer Star Wars you
know making out prom college football or
you know Premier League football 0-25 is
usually pretty happy
25 to 45 is what I call the [ __ ] gets
real ears you realize that distinct to
what your parents your unique told you
you're not gonna have a fragrance named
after you or be a member of Parliament
you have kids you have economic stress
someone you love a great deal gets sick
and dies your parents right
life gets very hard very fast 25 to 45.
and generally speaking these are the
least happy years
and then something wonderful happens
usually in your late 40s or early 50s
and that is you start recognizing the
finite nature of Life maybe you have
some economic security maybe you've
established relationships maybe you have
these really wonderful things that are
less awful that look smell and feel like
you called kids
and you realize that life is short you
start finding appreciate I don't know if
you remember this Steve do you remember
going out with your parents or your mom
and your mom would like a salad would
come and she'd stop the table and say
look at how beautiful the salad is yeah
or just admire the flowers and you think
you used to think as a kid like what the
[ __ ] like and when you realize it's so
weird when you turn into your
I stopped outside my house uh there's a
garden and I just couldn't stop
marveling at the Garden the garden's
here I've never seen anything like it we
have this Garden across from us in the
park and I'm like who are the Gnomes
that come out at night and manicure this
thing so perfectly and I'm not into
botany or Horticulture and I can't stop
marveling I wouldn't have done that in
my 27 year old self but I do it at my 57
I find you find joy in new things you
find joy in the mundane as you get older
and you get happier and the happiest
generation the happiest age cohort is
the cohort that should be the least
happy because they're not healthy is old
people
so what the learning here is that if you
wake up at 35 and you have a couple kids
and you have a spouse or you have a job
you know you think [ __ ] this is hard I'm
not that happy
recognize that's part of the journey and
just keep on keeping on you know
happiness Waits For You in most
instances
so happiness is absolutely a smile and
so I think it's helpful just to know
that that as you move into your income
earning years as you move into your
mating and child rearing years and the
depth of work and your parents start
aging it's stressful and it's hard and
if you're unhappy or feel unhappy at
times
that is normal that's part of the
journey and for me it was helpful to
read that because I'm looking forward to
all the happiness that's kind of coming
my way and I can feel it as you get
older you just start finding joy in
weird places when was the the pits of
your Ark in your life when was when were
your hardest years as it relates to
happiness
um
well losing my mom was tough for me
um but I think that the the pit for me
you're an entrepreneur the highs are
really high and the lows are really low
the closest I can equate it to is
is having a business like having a kid
you conceive the thing it looks smells
and feels like you and when it does well
it's just like when your kid scores a
goal or is doing great or seems happy
there's just no joy like that when
something how you have your world of
work you have your world of friends and
you have kids you have kids you have
sleep you'll find this out when
something goes wrong with one of your
kids the whole universe shrinks to what
is wrong with your kid I mean nothing
else matters and you just can't sleep
you're stressed you're upset you feel
feel you're on a cosmic level because
this Instinct that pours over us is if
your kid is failing you have failed on a
more Cosmic level because you haven't
been able to
protect that kid it's the same way with
a business so
when your business fails you just it's
impossible to remove yourself from that
failure my lowest moment probably
professionally was in the great
financial recession of 2008
in 99 I was a young man and was Wealthy
on paper I'd started several e-commerce
companies I didn't realize most of it
was not my fault that it was the market
and by the end of 2000 I was broke I
lost everything through the.com crash
clawed my way back to some level of
Economic Security in 2007 smacked again
in 2008 lost almost everything and then
my young son or my oldest had the poor
judgment to come marching out of my
girlfriend
so I was broke and I had a son a newborn
and a combination of the disappointment
professionally where I was now 40 years
old and wasn't economically where I
thought it would be was really upsetting
and and disappointing
and then the stress
when you're a dude with no spouse or
kids you can kind of dance Between The
Raindrops if you need to you can sleep
on a couch I was not going to make a
living I could support myself but living
in New York
uh having uh what felt like economic
failure business failure and a kid and
it's like okay my failures are now this
kid's failures
that was really stressful it was also
very motivating
you know I'd made some money so I had
made enough money to live kind of a a
kind of a a a fake wealthy life I had
nice clothes a nice apartment I could go
to St Barts I had just enough money to
give the illusion of success
but there's no faking it when you have
kids this person is dependent upon you I
was living in New York it's impossible
not to make a good living in New York
with kids
um and so that was wildly stressful it
was like okay this is no longer about me
when I fail economically I'm failing as
a species I'm feeling as a dad
uh that was a rough time
2008-2009 was rough but it was also very
motivating because I got very serious
and started working very hard and again
I didn't see my kids we had another kid
two and a half years later I didn't see
much of my kids until the age of five I
you know I try and get home for bath
time but I was very focused on getting
my household back on economic firm
footing again but that was very
stressful
that's your biggest sort of professional
failure what about your biggest
personal pit pit
um and what did it teach you oh I don't
know I I think are both your parents
still alive
yeah okay so one of them will get sick
and die and that is the the heart the
two things I found that kind of turn you
into an adult
are when you lose one of your parents
it's just the harshness of it is so
Unthinkable as a species we have an
inability to wrap our head around death
for good reason otherwise we'd all just
be freaked out and not willing to take
risks and not
hunt animals for fear they might kill us
not take risks never go outside so we
purposely can't understand it we can't
imagine it you can't imagine that this
person is going to be gone and it is
over
that is devastating and it it also just
brings this harshness of life like
really present in front of you
but at the same time it creates
tremendous perspective that wow the
mortality rate's 100 my kids are going
to have the same tragedy when I die and
I think it I think it can liberate you
and realize that okay if I feel
embarrassed if I feel scared about risks
if I'm beating myself up over a mistake
I made you know what it really doesn't
matter that much you should be kinder to
yourself you should be more forgiving
there's great work by my colleague at
NYU Adam alter on palliative care where
he surveys people who are weeks from the
end
and they have a lot of regrets they wish
they'd live the life they want to live
whether it was be more open about their
sexuality being who they wanted to be
with going to the career they wanted to
go with they were living their lives or
other people is a huge regret or Society
they wish they'd stayed in better
contact with friends
but more than anything their number one
regret is they wish they'd been less
harsh on themselves and that is again
life isn't about
what happens to you it's how you respond
to what happens to you and when someone
dies and you realize the finite nature
of life and we all have the same
incoming I think it's liberating because
what you realize is when you say
something stupid at a board meeting even
when you have a business fail when you
pick a stock and it gets cut in half in
two weeks and you're just hating on
yourself
when you say something stupid at a party
when you say something unkind
unwittingly and you're just like Jesus
what was I saying and you're just
beating yourself up
realize it's
the person you're worried about what
they think of you
your situation it's going to go really
fast and it's going to be over and all
you're going to have is the people that
miss you so you don't you need to
forgive yourself and you need to realize
what feels important in the moment isn't
that important
and I found it very liberating I was
devastated losing a parent and was
really my only parent but at the same
time it just gave me a lot of
perspective and then I think the second
moment in your life we start to grow up
is when you have a kid
because up until that moment and I'm
naturally a selfish person it comes it
comes very easily to me but it's the
first time in your life you're more
concerned with someone else's well-being
and it's it's it's a strange sense
to want someone else to be more
concerned about someone else's
well-being than yours I mean truly more
concerned and it's somewhat liberating
when I was your age on Friday I'd start
getting stressed like what fabulous
people am I hanging out with what
amazing thing am I doing how can I hang
around more interesting and hotter
people how can I have better experiences
sex more sex with hotter people make
more money make more money now it's like
okay
we got soccer practice Saturday morning
we got a playdates out it's all of a
sudden just about them I mean it's
literally just about them
and for the first few few years that
takes some adapting
but what you find I find it's relaxing
now to be more focused on someone else
I find is it is is relaxing and
rewarding instead of just all you all
the time right so losing someone and
gaining someone I think are the kind of
key moments
where you sort of uh grow up I mean
losing your parent is something that
happens to everybody
some the economic strain I have most
people would pray for but personal
troughs uh I've been really blessed so
far you talked a little bit there about
self-doubt come um do you do you
struggle with self-doubt oh yeah I have
a huge imposter syndrome but I think
it's healthy and I think most people
have it I think
um
yeah I I assure uh every time I've
raised money
I've thought I was fooling them and
committing fraud like oh God I just
raised 37 million dollars for my edtech
startup what were they thinking you know
what were they thinking
um
I don't you know I weird things like uh
I I get I'm sure you get fan mail or uh
if people who listen my podcast or want
to meet me or have dinner with me I
don't like to do it because I always
find they're going to be disappointed
that the person they think I am I'm just
not that interesting or that cool
um I I always worry that at the end of
the day my natural state will be to be
broken alone that that's kind of like
what my personality traits where they'll
Lead Me
um I have those fears every day I have
huge imposter syndrome
um
yeah so I but again it it's motivating
it's like well okay prove yourself and
them wrong so I wouldn't describe myself
I'm not a I'm I'm I'm confident on
certain levels but I always feel like a
little bit like every time I have an
achievement and I've like kind of fooled
everybody
do you know where that comes from
because I I'm not sure if that's
everybody I sit here with a lot of
people so I see a variance yeah I don't
know yeah I really don't know I don't
know where
um I don't know where it comes from but
yeah I definitely have something
whispering in my ear like you know who
the [ __ ] are you kidding and yeah that
you're you temp you fooled them
temporarily but it's all going to come
crashing down yeah I have that when I
was reading through a lot of things
you'd said about yourself you you also
had called yourself an [ __ ] a few
times
what do you mean by that and why were
you an [ __ ]
uh yeah some someone who wasn't kind
someone who put their own needs ahead of
other people I wasn't very kind of my
first wife I should have been uh as an
early manager I should have been kinder
to my employees yeah an [ __ ]
why why
wow I don't know I guess because I could
or I I don't know I like to think that
I've gotten better as I've gotten older
I think in America there's this
um at least and it's changing
in the world I grew up in and I think
it's kind of started with Steve Jobs
you know here's a guy who I think
there's this unfortunate Gestalt in
American Business that
if you're talented and super nice
you're talented
if you're talented and a bit of an
[ __ ] you're a genius
it was seen as leadership to be in a
room and and
get angry or point out the problems or
dress somebody down I think that's
changed for the better in the last 10
years
but everybody was trying to be Steve
Jobs
and there's no getting around it he was
cruel at work
he denied his own blood under oath to
avoid child support payments while it
was worth a quarter of a billion dollars
and that's the Jesus Christ of our
information age economy this was not a
kind man
and so in the Tech Community in the 90s
it was
uh kind of rewarded to be you know you
were a fighter right to be harsh
and I think a lot of that has changed
for the better you realize you know just
as you get older you're just younger
you're selfish and I think I've gotten
some early success
so I don't think I realize the extent to
which luck played a role in that
but I've gotten better
um um you know less of an [ __ ] what
has allowed you to increase your
self-awareness you just get older you
just get not you know you just get older
you realize
I remember I had one moment and I was at
a I was in a meeting I've always run my
own companies
yeah before I joined NYU I remember like
just nothing that big a deal but this
guy was presenting and he was having
some slides and I'm like I might go back
I'm like your sides make no [ __ ]
sense
I'm like just don't don't get us all in
a room and present this garbage just
kind of set it like that those exact
words
and he finished the presentation and
then we're all you know afterwards and I
went to the men's room and he was in the
men's room and he was next to me at the
funeral urinal and I saw his hand
shaking
he was so rattled by the thing that he
had like a small palsy or whatever you
call it and I remember thinking
you know I was finally getting to an H
where I could start to be a little bit
more self-aware and kind of mind what's
the point of all this [ __ ] success
if you just make other people feel like
[ __ ] like what's the point
and I thought why did I do that and some
of it was to communicate that this was
unacceptable and it was the data that
this person was presenting was
unacceptable but it would have been just
but part of it was for me to take the
opportunity to elevate my own stature
by diminishing someone else's
and that's entirely wrong and what you
realize as you get older
is that you don't need to diminish other
people's status to get to the same point
I should have taken him aside and said
come on man that data was you can do
better than that this is what was wrong
with it this is what how I think you
should present the data realize that
you're presenting to a group of people
who are going to notice that that data
contradicts the data on the next slide
and instead uh my need to feel I don't
know important to whatever put my own
needs ahead of theirs I think there's a
lot of that I don't think I don't think
it's a unique attribute but I I'd like
to think that I've starched most of most
of that out of my professional life
I think you just get older uh hopefully
you get Kinder you get more self-aware
but oh yeah I look back on my career
there's a lot I'm not proud of what are
you still working on personally
uh being present
you know you regret and uh upset about
the past anxiety about the future
uh take you so out of the present trying
to enjoy my sons at boarding school the
most difficult thing about moving here
is I come home my boy's not there my my
15 year old that's really strange for me
you'll see when your kids are around
they become a limb like when you're not
around your kids you feel as if
something's wrong I mean the first
the first day away from them is amazing
and then it gets awful you're like oh
God this is wonderful I can sleep in you
know I used to like business travel
especially when they're babies babies
are tough
but now you feel like you're like you're
like walking around without a limb it
just it's just weird and my son's in
boarding school here and so coming home
and not having him home is just very
uh very strange so when he was home
yesterday he's only home for a day and a
half on the weekends trying to be very
in the moment trying to be present I
have a tough time one of my talents is
an entrepreneur I think is that I'm
always thinking about work and focused
on [ __ ] so when I show up Monday morning
I've kind of got a head start because
I'm thinking about problems I'm thinking
about stuff
but the problem is you're not that
present and it's very hard to balance
those two because it's so competitive I
mean I would imagine I look around I I
know your success I would imagine you're
constantly thinking about work right
thinking about new new ways to improve
things people you can reach out to
emails you should send to encourage
people you know just constantly think
about it once you have kids
it's very hard to manage that balance
because you want to be present
so I'm trying to be present also I'm
trying to slow time down time is falling
off a cliff for me
um I have a chat group with my college
friends it was yesterday
you know when we were in college
it's it's just flown by the last 30
years
which means it's going to go even faster
and I'm going to be 87.
trying to slow time down trying to be
more present that's what I'm working on
and uh uh you know just trying to be
kinder I think I think everyone should
from day one just think okay how can I
be more kind how do we slow time down my
my uh my friend asked me today what my
superpower would be and that's what I
said I said I wish I could pause time
yeah I might like I think it's toxic my
own stuff I was like because then I
could get my work done yeah yeah and
continue with with my life and then
maybe I could DJ and learn you know some
other things but my I've always said
that that would be my chosen superpower
but how does one practically slow time
down so that 30 years doesn't fly past
so when you're a dad one of the things
you realize is
you have this image that belief that
your kids are going to be into World War
II history and Crossfit those are the
things I'm interested in and when you
find out is kids have their own
interests and if you want to be a good
dad you have to lean into their
interests otherwise you're just not
going to have a very strong relationship
with them because they they're selfish
kids are inherently selfish and they're
like oh well Dad's really into World War
II history so I'll go to the
you know the the British war museum and
I'll find it fascinating you know that
doesn't happen my kids so yesterday I
ended up at life-size Monopoly which is
this life-size Monopoly game somewhere
and then for me that's the seventh ring
of hell that's just that's the stuff but
what you try to do to slow time down is
I immediately go into like okay just
ignore the thing you know check your
email be a good dad just do get through
it get through it
I find that you can slow time down by
getting into stuff like trying to like
so I really try and get in get into
life-size Monopoly and engage with my
child and like be a little bit over the
top about it and when they do cheers
scream like try and just get
really into things
because if you want time to pass it will
it'll cooperate but when you get really
into stuff even though you think it's
stupid and cheesy and you're like can't
help but think
God this is like Chinese water torture
um I find that slows it down I also find
leaning into your emotions or slows time
down
because it makes you more present
I didn't cry or laugh out loud from the
ages of 30 to 44 for 14 years I didn't
cry once and I didn't laugh out loud I
forg I lost the capacity to
uncontrollably laugh and to cry I just
kind of forgot how to do either of those
things
and emotions are things you have to
practice so I remember the first time I
started crying and the first time I
really laughed out loud with friends I
thought God did both these things feel
great and I started getting really into
those things and feeling
guilt when I do something stupid or like
trying to really embrace my emotions
because that indicates what's important
to you what moves you and inspires you
what upsets you what pisses you off and
I find emotions like real raw emotions
when you register them and absorb them
and like lean into the messy part of
yourself I find that slows time down so
getting into stuff and registering your
emotions and as a business person you're
taught to be a little bit stoic you have
this weird sense also as a man of
masculinity that men don't feel their
emotions but you you start forgetting
what's important to you you start
forgetting what like Israel your things
you're into like what what do you find
hilarious what makes you well up with
tears because you find it so moving
without being without doing that stuff
you forget what's important to you you
forget like you kind of lose your
individualism
anyway so there's and you talked to
Simon Seneca there's a bunch of people
who have a lot of means uh those are my
those are my two tricks
in your book the algebra of Happiness
the third section is about health and we
spoke earlier about the importance of it
I've really recently over the last two
years I'd say learn the importance of
health and make sure I work out pretty
much every day what are why is health so
important you know I've I've been on my
own journey to understand it but um one
of the things you said was that the most
common trait among CEOs is that they
exercise regularly
um and even that you said you've made
comments about alcohol being bad for us
did you did you take time to learn that
I know you've been working out since you
were very very young but the overarching
role of our health in everything
um
what have you learned about that and the
importance of it oh it's kind of where
it all starts I mean this is not a
rental you know it's not a trust
rehearsal your body is it I mean you
look you you look like an athlete what
do you do every day what do you thank
you I'll clip that
um and I'll put that in my bio
um I do a mixture so I train for an hour
every day um Jemima's in my fitness
group so about 90 of days a year we we
train
um yesterday was CrossFit uh yeah
yesterday was CrossFit so yeah so look
if you could do something that would
make you less depressed
make you more likely to be successful
broaden your selection set of mates
I mean wouldn't wouldn't you want to
take that drug every day it's called
exercise we're happiest as a species in
motion surrounded by others we've been
hunting and Gathering so the things
you're going to remember in your life
are usually not the CrossFit class but
walking around Rome with your family and
your kids complaining but being outside
in some form of exercise
with people you care about so an
exercise and feeling strong
uh I mean it's been my antidepressant if
I don't you know I got here four three
four days ago I've only worked out once
I can feel myself I'm angrier I'm not as
nice I don't feel as good about myself
it's I think for a lot of people it is
it is the easiest means to an
antidepressant it's the closest thing we
have to a youth serum you have this
basically 24x7 security camera on in
your brain trying to figure out if
you're adding value that's the bad news
the good news is it's got terrible
resolution and you can fool it
so if you're caring for other people
caregivers generally live longer because
your brain will sense that you're caring
for other people you're social you're
touching people you're concerned and it
releases a hormone that lets you stay
alive new mothers typically do not die
um if you're exercising intensely it
fools the camera into believing that
you're hunting prey or building housing
and it says let's keep this person
around longer
so it is a great antidepressant it's a
great use serum
um I find you're just Kinder you're
nicer you're more confident so you know
it's I again the thing that the Fortune
500 CEOs have most in common it's not
the schools they went to it's not even
their it's not even their ethnicity it
is gender only 483 of them are men but
more than any practice or attribute it's
that they work out four to five times
plus a week physical fitness again it's
one of my algorithms
you should not watch other people sweat
for any longer than you sweat and I you
know
if if you're watching other people sweat
four hours a week and you're sweating
one hour a week you're in trouble
do not you have to sweat more than you
watch other people sweat
the other thing we have in common is um
our backgrounds in advertising yeah and
brand you speak a lot about branding and
advertising
um I sat here with Rory Sutherland and
that was one of our real best performing
episodes so I didn't realize there was
such a demand on from our audience in
terms of practical advertising knowledge
he talked a lot about Apple and Tesla
and the sequence there how has the the
the the lands of advertising and a brand
building a reputation changed in your
lifetime and what is the most important
thing for Brands to understand now or
some of the important things for Brands
to understand now if they are to be
successful
yeah so my first job in business school
I started a company called profit brand
strategy that's now about 500 people and
now it's just called profit and the
basic notion was it was based on the
principles of my professor my second
year David Ocker is considered the
father of modern branding
and it was that the intangible
associations with a brand or set of
products or services are the only
sustainable advantage
that if you can wrap
a set of products and services with
these brand codes of masculinity
European Elegance Youth and then pound
away at those associations
using this incredibly chat cheap
efficient medium called broadcast
advertising you can take a marginal shoe
salty snack marginal car
and get amazing margins on it so that
was that's been from the end of World
War II to the introduction of Google in
the 90s the algorithm for creating
massive shareholder wealth was find a
mediocre product rapid in amazing brand
codes and make people feel more
patriotic or more or younger
stuff the Channel with it and print
money the pngs the pepsicos of the world
you know the coca-colas these are the
economic Titans of yesteryear the sun
has passed midday on that because our
weapons of diligence whether it's Google
or TripAdvisor Amazon reviews now gets
us to the best product without the
benefit of this weapon of diligence
called brand when I come came to London
I used to stay at the Four Seasons from
the Mandarin Oriental why because
someone else was paying and they're
always an eight
and then I went on TripAdvisor and I
went on my social graph and I found out
the people of the Comet hotel or people
of the Ferndale Hotel so I started
staying at the Haymarket why I like a
place with a nice gym and I want to stay
out with hang out with people who are
younger and cooler than me
so I started staying in boutique hotels
so all of a sudden
product became the bomb again and then
your ability to embrace these new
mediums around social became more
important than broadcast advertising so
the traditional metrics of branding the
traditional vehicles for Branding a
brand identity and broadcast advertising
that I've been preaching in brand
strategy the sun has passed midday if
you look at my curriculum and the
majority of curriculums and marketing
departments You could argue that we're
just training people to go to work at
Unilever or General Mills and be laid
off 24 months later
uh branding has become much more about
Innovation and actual product quality
now that extends into how you discover
the product how you absorb the product
the community around it
but you know Tesla is a better product
Apple used to be an underpowered product
with a great brand now it's a great
brand with a superior product
so these Airbnb is a much better product
these things are Google is 10x better
than what was there before it
so supply chain
uh design the way you absorb the product
it's ease of use
you know it's just it's moved from kind
of what you call a brand economy to
about lack of a better term an
innovation economy
so
rather than taking classes on
Advertising I say take classes on supply
chain or analytics or really understand
industrial design
you know there was a general feeling
that all product quality had maxed out
and then the internet came along and
unlocked all this product Innovation so
cars they felt had hit kind of a peak in
terms of product quality
and then all of a sudden with the
internet and GPS you could you could
tune a car up uh wirelessly
you can unlock the doors there's all
kinds of the crazy things you could do
with it uh in addition to a in addition
to EV I mean there's just been so much
actual Innovation around the product and
what are the most valuable companies in
the world have in common
they either spend no money on
advertising or they're spending less
Apple's the strongest brand in the world
at least a consumer brand I would argue
the strongest man in the world
universities but it's reallocated
six or seven billion dollars out of
broadcast advertising into its channel
into store to build 550 temples of the
brand and I think that is almost part of
the product my 12 year old and I were
born yesterday so we went to the Apple
Store so that's kind of consuming the
product and I end up buying screensavers
and new cases that I'm sure 90 points a
gross margin that I could find to finac
or Best Buy or someone for less money
but we want to be in that store in that
environment
so it's it's moving on a pre-purchase
broadcast advertising into the
distribution Channel and into Innovation
but the traditional
the traditional Norms of marketing or
branding as I taught it
that shit's over Don Draper has been
drawn and quartered if you're watching a
lot of advertising it means your life
hasn't worked out
the majority of people who are
technically literate
or
wealthy can avoid 80 90 advertising now
they watch Netflix they they subscribe
to Spotify they live in cities where
they have local officials that demand
you can't see a billboard from a park
um so
advertising is a tax on the poor and the
technologically illiterate so it's moved
to more distribution and Innovation but
for God's sakes don't
you know avoid the falling into the Trap
of thinking that the Masters of the
Universe or branders or advertisers
if they are innovators then how does one
make make themselves with a team
Innovative this is the question I get
asked all the time yeah when I speak at
conferences or to businesses as well you
know how do we how do we make our 500
people in our company and innovate
because you'll see the CEO standing you
know in front of the the board meeting
on all the All Hands and say we need to
be more Innovative yeah what does that
mean right that's for cool we all know
that yeah but by Design how do how do we
create an Innovative mindset ourselves
or Innovative teams
that's a tough one I don't consider
myself
an expert on culture although
is clearly out there like I think of HBO
HBO if there's a show that people are
talking about I don't know the same is
true but in the US people are talking if
there's a show people talking about the
water cooler it's Euphoria it's
succession
it's generally an HBO show and they have
about a third of the budget of some of
the other streaming networks so there's
something about that culture where
they're able to come up with kind of
breakthrough
creative some companies just seem to do
that time and time again agreed and so
it's a culture thing at the heart of it
even Apple you know yeah especially in
the era of Steve Jobs they seem to
take it's an unbelievably scary
um bets that paid off so obviously a lot
of them don't some of them don't but
Amazon's the same AWS the Kindle 100
yeah so you know I mean you know there's
some Basics it's a willingness to fail
to take big bets to reward people for
taking risks I think an external
Viewpoint that's constantly benchmarking
other companies I mean my last reml too
essentially what we did was we went out
and bench part marked the best practices
of every company in Social e-commerce
payments and then came in and said okay
Unilever okay Nike what can you learn
from everyone from Adidas
to Tata Motors like what are they doing
that's really interesting so having an
external Viewpoint a willingness to take
big bats I also think holding people
accountable found a little businesses
seem to to be much more Innovative
obviously I think they often fail
quicker as well but they seem to have a
higher risk appetite than a great
founder-led businesses
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast all right where the last guest
leaves a question for the next guest
they don't know who they're leaving it
for
and I didn't get to read it until open
the book
um
the question that's been left for you
okay
do I get to know who left it you don't I
don't know okay
what is your biggest regret personally
and if you could go back what would you
do differently
uh it's kind of the questions that are
obviously my biggest regret
personally
I wish I had been Kinder from an earlier
age I think it's good for the world I
think it makes me feel more masculine
it makes me feel more successful to be
kind and I didn't stumble upon that I
wish I'd I'd come to that realization
sooner
that to be generous to be loving to be
you know the uh synagogue a friend of
mine says that the
the most wasted resource is good
intentions
I wish my good intentions had
I was more ready more confident to
articulate the kind thoughts I had about
others and to articulate them with more
ease I've thought good things about
other people I've wanted to do good
things for a long time
but I didn't have the confidence or the
discipline to either say them or do them
I wish I'd had that confidence earlier
because the majority of us are good
people the majority of us admire other
people the majority of us love other
people
and we don't want to articulate it I
think especially men because we're
worried that saying I admire you or you
know you're just such a handsome young
buff man who's who's acquired so much
success at a young age I'm kind of like
trying to figure out I'd love to know
like how did you do all this at such a
young age saying that is embarrassing
for a man there's this feeling among men
that me saying that makes me less
successful and masculine like it's a
zero-sum game and what you realize as
you get older is that is
that is how you feel strong and how you
feel kind I wish I'd figured that out
earlier I wish I'd been more
forthcoming with my positive emotions
does that end up making us miserable
personally so if I if I hold that kind
of it's almost a form of resentment
isn't it we I think we all have I think
when Justin Bieber came onto the scene
and I looked over and there was this
like 14 year old that had all the women
and he was beautiful and he was selling
out these Arenas I'm thinking [ __ ] it
this guy or Shan Freud I mean it's just
resentment of other people's success I
think that's different I think I think
Justin Bieber wants some hate
um but for sure but the reason I I was
hating on him was purely jealousy it was
fair enough but I my sense is you seem
pretty self-actualizer your age I was at
the age of 30 as an entrepreneur
if my team was doing a great job
and there was a great shot
I rewarded them at the end of the year
with a bonus
as you get older what you realize is
young people need watering it doesn't
matter how successful they are it
doesn't have much money they're making
when you say I sent a text this morning
we did a my property has this new thing
called we have something called the
markets podcast which is focused on the
markets
the team did such an amazing job with
the sound edits today and it's a 24 year
old
it's a 24 year old doing this [ __ ] and
she has such a feel her name's Claire
Miller she has such a feel for how to
integrate Sound and Music and knows when
to fade it in and fade it out and I
immediately register that and I think oh
me registering that is really good for
her because I'm the boss
well why wouldn't you pull out your
phone and say your integration of sound
here is so striking and your talent is
so
ahead of where you are and I did that
and I know when she wakes up this
morning and gets that text message it's
just gonna
make her morning it's just gonna make
her morning
20 years ago I didn't think to do that
why I don't know I just didn't do it
just didn't I don't know selfish didn't
want to give up that again saw it as
someone of lazy
not kind I don't know is there an
element of thinking that if you give the
compliment then someone can become
complacent or they can become they might
not strive as hard maybe I don't know I
saw my job as a CEO back when was
um all over everybody all of the time I
mean just all the time and I'm still
like that and not as bad a little bit as
well and look there's that's you can do
that and still be kind I was on a panel
with other CEOs and they ask what is
your management philosophy
and this one woman who runs a very
successful uh startup said
it's putting people on the role to
succeed and the other one and the other
person said it's it's helping people
find their true self finding what
they're really passionate about and then
it came to me like I'm all [ __ ] over
everybody all of the [ __ ] time and
every you know I just went dark I don't
know how else to do it I'm just all over
and I realized maybe that's why I've
never been able to grow a billion dollar
business because I'm just too I don't
say in the weeds I do give people uh I
think a decent amount of latitude but I
don't know how else to do it just to you
know kind of
be all over everything all of the time I
don't maybe that's why again I don't I'm
not running a multi-billion dollar
franchise
I can relate
I can relate
um I can relate to that a lot
but that's a conversation for another
time I guess because
it's not as much about me but thank you
Scott for your time and you're with you
I followed you for some time and I
remember going out to Bali a couple of
years ago grabbing the book in the
airport when I was off to write my own
book so I your book was a source of
inspiration for me I remember reading it
on my desk there in Ubud
um and that's why I was surprised it
wasn't behind me today but I guess it's
upstairs and your your [ __ ] free
approach to sharing yourself and your
ideas is
incredibly important we I think we've
seen a sort of a decline in a
willingness to be both vulnerable
um and brutally honest about our
perspectives and doesn't mean what our
perspectives are always correct but but
the Collision of two ideas that are
honest I think is how we ultimately lead
to progress so I love that and that's
why we ultimately have this podcast your
new book a drift America and 100 charts
is out now yep
why did you write that book
of all the things you you know you know
so much about so many things you talk
about so many topics why that book
um I'm fascinated with the idea of a
nation and connective tissue I feel very
patriotic as I get older I'm more
grateful for my blessings and one of my
blessings I talked about was being born
in America
and I wanted I love charts we've been
communicating with words since the
alphabet for 1500 years but we've been
communicating with images whether it was
reading them off the cave cave walls or
the walls of caves or looking at the
height of the Sun in the sky for tens of
thousands so I've always been really
drawn to charts we can process
information six to sixty times faster
when it's visual
so I thought how can I create a
narrative around what ails America and
what are some of the solutions with
charts so it's a chart and then a
narrative second chart and a narrative
all grouped into themes and also I just
want to write a book every 12 to 15
months I feel like it's the hardest
thing I do but I feel like it keeps me
sort of young
and some of those narratives are
conversations we've had today but
explained in more context
um and all of your books have been
important for me it's because of the way
that you write it's not it's not just
the content itself but it's writing in
such an accessible way which can make a
very complicated theme be accessible to
someone like me who is not I don't
consider myself to be an intellectual in
any capacity and thank you for your time
today uh it's a real Stroke of Luck that
you now live in London and you're able
to be here and do this and I feel very
honored that you came so thank you I
appreciate that congratulations on all
your success thank you so much Scott
it's a pleasure
quick one from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events there
is a really exciting new product coming
from Hill which the founder Julian told
me about yesterday on WhatsApp
um and it's something I've wanted from
you for a long time because when I look
at my kind of nutrition stack the things
that I have and consume every single day
to keep me performing at my best in a
good shape and healthy there's one thing
missing which you'll currently don't do
and to get that message from Julian
yesterday and to know it's on it's on
its way is tremendously exciting the
thing about hula is they always focus on
a couple of core principles which is
making sure that the the stuff inside
the products are not only nutritionally
complete but they're sourced from
suppliers that provide the best quality
nutritions and to know that fuel are now
going into more categories that are
essential to my nutrition stack is
incredibly exciting so if you're
starting your fuel Journey or you
haven't started your fuel Journey my
recommendation is to get the starter
pack they have on the website I'll link
it down below and that gives you a
little bit of all the products in a box
and then from that you can decide which
products are for you and where they fit
in your life and I think if you're
anything like me you might just fall in
love with the brand
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]